I never fit in anywhere to Iranian in
America to American and Iran
the only way to survive was to not put
my faith in any of the rules nice
cultural commentary obviously I've had
some issues with culture can you blame
me
what was she saying I'm pregnant how can
you be so irresponsible this is my mom
and I's relationship in a nutshell she's
the queen of stubbornness a trait I'd
later go on to perfect Layla Elena Hi
how are you evidently better than you
I'm trying it's not all my mom's fault I
believe in you but it's so much easier
blaming our mothers how do you say
goodbye in Persian Cafe sure everybody
[Music]
we read the All-American family
trust me on this
[Music]